[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you also
need to watch the nba on tnt on tuesday
nights
because my guy adam lefkow is absolutely
killing it he's also got the lefko show
on bleacher report which i've been on by
the way and hopefully we'll be on again
soon i want to get
adam on the ross tucker podcast soon to
talk a little nba
and talk a little about eagles he's an
eagles fan he's bumming me out with some
of his tweets lately
he's bumming me out a little bit so i'll
get to that in a little bit you gotta
tune in
to adam on bleacher reports br gridiron
draft night
live across the br app br gridiron
twitter
and youtube channels starting thursday
april 29th
at 8 00 pm eastern connor rogers akeeb
to leave
reggie wayne and robert griffin iii
will also be part of it let's go what's
up man
you know it's not often i get compared
to a van but when i do
i hope it's from last tucker first of
all you hear how awesome his voice is
you know how smooth it is
it's like a it's like a mercedes-benz
van
i know i've asked just before adam how
did you get your voice like that it
wasn't oh like
you your voice is not like that when you
were 16. my voice is awful right now
because i am fighting
something in my sinuses that i don't
even know what it is
uh last time i came on here dan patrick
absolutely sunned me
and he brought out the pipes uh i think
i've talked about this before i hated my
voice for a long time ross
i went to syracuse to rico costas
it's like beautiful and then i come in
and people say i sound like a 40 year
old divorcee
and so like it's like rough like i've
been i've been like inhaling cigars
and so i used to hate my voice but to
get compliments from you is refreshing
i think it's glorious i think it's like
a a
smooth sultry voice although paulie just
said he thinks it sounds like demi moore
yeah oh in a good way have you ever
heard that before it is a little there
is a little demi moore in there
i i've never heard that i'm gonna i'm
gonna go and just watch youtube clips of
demi moore
uh shaq likes my voice too if you ever
check out his instagram
he he thinks i have a really good white
guy voice
like when i really tile up the white guy
voice
so if i'm like if i'm like well hello
good to see you
he thinks it's like how all white men
should sound
all right so here's the question about
shaq
is he the same guy off the air because
you and i both know
some people exact same guy on the air
and off the air
like me some people very very different
watch category shack in shaq doesn't
have an
opportunity to not be shaq because
everywhere he walks in
everyone's like oh shaq and so
what what i've learned through shaq i'm
going to do a little bit of a deep dive
military background dad super super
disciplinarian
moved all over the country and he was
always as you can imagine
this enormous kid and so he just began
watching tv and seeing comedy and was
like oh
it's a lot easier to meet people if i'm
just hilarious all the time
and so with shaq you just don't know
what you're going to get
ross like you come off set and he's in
the back djing
and he's just like and he's like i know
i know lefko likes this all white people
like this
[Laughter]
and like either that or he's doing like
food reviews or he's like throw grapes
in my mouth while i'm sleeping like
it never turns off it's the biggest kid
i've ever met
but it's always how can my team succeed
man so it's he's
he is him all the time doesn't change
everybody i know
that knows him loves him and says he's
like the legit
awesomest guy love to hear it uh
speaking of shaq
his former team lakers they got anthony
davis back last night that's like the
big news in the nba last night
do you think with davis back when they
get lebron
back you still think they got a pretty
good chance to do this again
you know anthony davis to attend four
points
that's not back for anthony davis but
uh i was if the lakers have anthony
davis and lebron
and they are healthy and it is the
playoffs they are the favorite to win
the championship
because we've seen this story too many
times
you know and also i look around the rest
of the league
and i'm seeing a lot of issues
everywhere else
philadelphia i go okay tobias harris ben
simmons in the playoffs kind of scary
utah no one's going to believe it until
they see it
phoenix is a little bit too early in the
process can deandre ayton really guard
anthony davis
the clippers no one's believing it
because they haven't done it in the
playoffs
denver's injured brooklyn they're never
playing together they've been together
for seven games
and milwaukee i feel like is in the same
boat as utah
and the clippers where we're going we've
seen you
lose in the playoffs before so i think
if lebron and anthony davis are healthy
they are the favorites and the big
question is if because anthony davis
didn't look
that healthy last night all right so
what if all of the nets are healthy what
what if they have the big three
oh yeah that's scary because they're not
favorites if they if they have hardened
durant and kyrie all healthy all planned
they're not the favorites
i so the lakers are the favorites in the
west the nets would be the favorite in
the east
the reason that i give it to the west is
i'm not someone that likes to bet
against lebron a lot
especially because they have the
experience of getting there
it to me the nets are you know in the
nfl playoffs
when all of a sudden they don't call
past interference as much and they let
you kind of get a little bit more
physical and bill belichick just knows
exactly what to do
yeah in the nba it turns into a half
court game
and it's not about utah's passing and
accuracy and all that
it's can you score by yourself
and brooklyn's ability to score with
harden
kyrie and kd is unmatched i would still
give a slight edge to the lakers because
they have some continuity
but that is the finals that i'm i'm
rooting for because i
all the story lines kd undefeated
against the lebronic no no no two and
one against lebron because of the
thunder time
kyrie taking on lebron again if james
harden wins a championship ross
like james harden i think i may have
said this before
if james harden wins a championship it's
kind of like if matt stafford wins a
championship with the rams
where it's like man he's like a top five
passing yards guy like all of a sudden
so much is validated i i just love the
story lines of that matchup
all right so first of all that is not
our preferred match-up
you grew up outside of philadelphia we
want the sixers to beat the net
so i gotta say i really dislike the nets
i don't like any aspect of how they were
put together
i don't think any of those guys are
likable
i mean kyrie i won't even go there
durant
is not really likable because of what he
did going to golden state and everything
and harden how he got out of houston i
i want the sixers to beat the net so bad
i can taste it i would say other than
football
the sixers beating the nets this year is
one maybe one of the most important
sports events for me
personally in like the last 10 years
because i'm a sixers fan the sixers
drafted embiid
they drafted simmons i've been waiting
for this and i just
don't like anything about the nets i
don't like the super team i don't like
how they brought these guys together
i don't like the players themselves am i
is that my sixers bias or do you think a
lot of people
dislike the nets as a former offensive
lineman
that just waxed poetic about girl
softball
you not liking the nets is the most
predictable take i've ever heard
there is a generational divide
about the brooklyn nets people over a
certain age
that love barry sanders because he
tossed the ball of the ref after a play
hate the brooklyn nets people in my
generation and a little bit younger
get it and here's the reason why imagine
you are a 28 year old that grew up
listening to dan patrick listening to
sportscenter
and hearing them go you know why michael
jordan's the goat because he's got six
rings
you know why he's better than him
because he has more rings than him
we have baked it into these young guys
brains
that the only way they can be treated as
champions
is they went on the biggest stage so for
kevin durant to go and do what he did
he was just fulfilling the prophecy that
people like dan patrick were setting for
him
i think that i am someone that tries to
understand kyrie
i am not someone that that thinks that
uh
he i think everybody looks the flat
earth comments
and they go how could you listen to
anything since then i think he has a lot
of very
wise things to say i think he talked
recently about language
and the n-word and i thought it was very
enlightening i think that he has been a
leader
in terms of um the black lives matter
movement
and a lot of things in the bubble i
think there's a lot of thought in which
he does
i think james harden the way he exited
is
not very uh well liked by a lot of
people i agree with that
at the same point i am someone that
believes in the player empowerment era
i am also someone that like if i was
down there in houston
like i don't besmirch blake griffin
wanting to leave
detroit because he signed a five-year
deal with the clippers and then in year
one got traded to detroit
like why why would i want him to want to
play there that's crazy so
i look at it as i'm just trying to enjoy
the journey of these guys
and they've come together and one of my
favorite experiences was a 72 and 9
warriors team i like to watch things
i've never seen before
i i do like the brooklyn nets and what
they're doing right now because i like
watching
players when they are happy watching
james harden when he is happy
has been one of my most favorite
basketball experiences this season
leading the nba in assist doing
everything he needs to do it's been very
enjoyable so
i i do counter you but i would love to
see the sixers beat the nets i really
would
who's the mvp nicole jokic
he's top 10 in points in rebounds in
assists
they are fourth in the west they are 18
games over 500
the sixers are 19 games over 500 he
loses jamal murray
they keep it rolling they've won four in
a row since jamal murray goes out
and yeah joel embiid has missed a number
of games and they played pretty well in
those games i would go
jokic won i would go embiid two
i would go it would have been hardened
for a little bit i would go steph curry
three
just because what we're seeing out of
steph curry is incredible
uh to be able i believe he's had six
games
of ten or more threes this year and no
one that is active right now has had
five has had more than five in their
entire career
so i i would put him three last question
why are you so down on the birds man
like your your tweets are bumming me out
you're so
down on siri not down on the birds i'm
that
okay why are you sitting down telling
him he's just starting give him a chance
rock paper scissors rock paper scissors
that's how he's
he ross how am i supposed to listen to
this man at a press conference
who's out there his first press
conference because here's my reason
okay when the eagles were looking for a
head coach ross tucker there was a lot
of guys out there that were super
qualified
but here they hire nick ciriani and why
did they hire him
because he wowed them in the interview
process
and the only thing that i can see to get
the experience of what jeff laurie and
howie roseman saw
are the press conferences and so if he
was wowed
and then he gives press conferences in
which he says we do rocks paper scissors
or the clip that i posted that went
super viral and i was not expecting that
in which he said
um that i i don't even know it was
rambling into nothing and i have former
eagles
texting me saying that we should be
concerned
ross i'm asking you other than blind
faith where are you getting any
confidence from nick syria
i i like the energy and the passion i i
like
that he's energetic here's the thing
here's what matters adam he's got to be
like this
with the players like i need to know i
i'll be interested you know i do their
preseason games on tv i'll be interested
to talk with him
and see how genuine it is i think it is
like i see him on enough things now
i think it is genuine and as long as
you're that guy
all the time i think the players
will like it but you got to be that guy
all the time you got to be authentic you
know what i wanted
i wanted a coach that's really good at
play calling
and play development i want somebody
that's so much smarter than everybody
else
that they can develop also like this
isn't college football
constant encouragement super positivity
when you've lost three games in a row
you've been in a locker room is that
message really going to resonate
guys we're so close we're so close come
on let's get some competition
they're going to tune him out so fast
look i want it to work
i want jalen hurts to be great shoot
draft jaylen waddle at 12.
jalen hurts jaylen rager jalen waddle
jalen's everywhere it'll be great
i just think i just think that it it
sounds like some high school pep talk
stuff
that i just don't think resonates with
grown men because it's a grown man team
that's a yeah
yeah i i guess we're going to find out
check him out
on social at adam lefkow and again tune
in
reporter you hear how he's talking he's
a company man he's on that eagles
payroll baby i love that no
that's a good dude right there no i'm
giving him the benefit of the doubt i am
giving him the benefit for the doubt
i said to you i want to see what he's
like with me one-on-one you know when
i'm talking with him like that i want to
see
how genuine authentic he is adam always
genuine authentic
br gridiron twitter youtube just follow
him on social he'll post what he's doing
on draft night with akeeb to leave
everybody thank you adam
hey i'm the mercedes-benz vans of humans